but first Corona virus is spreading
faster in Scotland than in many other
parts of the UK and to talk about that
we're joined from Glasgow by first
Minister Nicholas sturgeon thank you
very much for being with us um I just
want to talk about the situation in
Scotland when it comes to coid 19 um
cases doubling every nine days across
the UK the doubling time is between
eight and 16 days so that puts Scotland
at the upper end of that on Friday the r
rate in Scotland was between 1.3 and 1.7
that's higher than in England suggesting
that people in Scotland are spreading
the virus more have you lost control of
Co 19 in
Scotland no absolutely not and we're
working hard to make sure that that
doesn't happen H the our number the
doubling time the latest figures
suggested you've just said there that it
is spreading a little bit faster but our
number of cases per 100,000 of the
population are actually at the lowest
level of all of the UK Nations and that
is partly because over the summer we
suppressed the virus to very low levels
so the rate of spread we're seeing now
is from a much much lower base now that
doesn't mean that we can be complacent
about it or not take it very seriously
but it does show we a right to do that
over the summer and I think we're right
now to act quickly and decisively to try
to stop that increase in cases which is
why we took last week the very difficult
decision to close down at pubs and
restaurants in the central about of
Scotland but also restrict their
operations in every part of Scotland one
of the things we learned earlier on in
the year I think we all learned this was
that speed of action against this virus
is really important literally every day
matters you say there that the virus
level in Scotland went very low over the
summer which it did so I'm really
interested to know why has it started to
rise so sharply again what's driving it
is it students is it the fact that
people really aren't obeying the social
distancing rules anymore what's what's
going on in some always it's it's quite
basic and actually it's the phenomenon
we're seeing in many other countries not
just in the UK but across Europe right
now we suppressed the virus at to very
low levels because of lockdown we then
lifted lockdown a little bit more slowly
than in other parts of the UK but as
Lockdown measures are lifted and people
start to interact with each other more
then the virus gets more opportunities
to spread we're also going into winter
we're not in the depth of winter yet but
temperatures are falling a little bit so
the condition for the virus start to
become more favorable for it in terms of
the spread of it we also and this may
have an impact on our slightly and I
want to stress slightly higher our
number Scottish schools went back as
they do every year earlier than in other
parts of the UK and we were determined
to get schooled back full time for the
the good of children and their education
and universities in Scotland go back a
little bit earlier than other parts of
the UK as well so there's a a multitude
of factors there but what is important
is that we try to strike a balance
between living as best we can with this
virus retaining some of the freedoms
that we didn't have during the very
strict lockdown but still making sure
that we're keeping it under control we
also have a very well functioning test
and protect system in Scotland which is
now bearing a lot of the strain of
breaking the chains of transmission and
keeping it under control let's talk
about the testing system shall we what's
the weekday testing capacity in
Scotland it varies we have two strands
of of testing capacity we've got the
lighthouse laboratory UK wide Network
and the capacity there varies but if you
look at yesterday for example just under
20,000 tests were carried out in
Scotland we also have the capacity just
just straight on so what is the week day
about so in in a week day taking all of
the different parts of capacity it will
be between 30 and 40,000 tests a day
given between up to 40,000 a day just
looking at the number of test carried
out in Scotland on Monday it was 15,000
Tuesday 13,000 Wednesday 177,000
Thursday 18,000 Friday 18,000 when we
know the R8 is rising in Scotland
infections are rising the virus is
spreading why on Earth aren't you using
the full testing capacity well much of
the testing capacity remember is demand
lead is people with symptoms and that's
what we want to ensure as we go into the
deeper part half of the testing capacity
you're saying that you've got a great
test and Trace system but if you're
using half less than half of the testing
when the r rate is going up when
infections are going up it's not doesn't
sound like a wellbeing system to me with
respect I was about to try to explain it
to you before um you sto me we are
building and have been building a
testing capacity that is is not just
what we require now but what we will
required as we go into winter so H we
want to make sure that we have that
spare capacity as we go into winter we
are likely to see more people with
symptoms that maybe symptoms of coid or
maybe symptoms of flu so that we have
that capacity there because this is to a
large extent a demand Le system and of
course we have in terms of the
availability of tests whether that's
through you know Regional testing
centers Mobile testing units the
walkthrough centers we've got H we have
quick and ready access to to testing but
we are also looking um at expanding
testing of groups in the population that
don't have symptoms so we already test
uh people who work in Care Homes we test
groups of NHS staff and one of the
things I aned in Parliament just a few
days ago is over this twoe period we're
looking at extending testing into other
asymptomatic groups and we of course
making sure that we've got the capacity
to do that as well what I was going to
say is we have two shs of capacity the
lighthouse lab processing capacity but
also NHS Scotland capacity where we are
transferring Care Home testing too so
that we maximize all of the capacity
we've got but in terms of people
understandably and legitimately say why
don't you use all of your capacity uh
right now now um we want to test as many
people as come forward right now but we
also want to make sure as we go into the
winter we've got the capacity we will
need then okay now you mentioned a bit
earlier in the interview the new
restrictions that you've brought in uh
in Scotland to try and slow the spread
of the virus um of course if people are
to follow the rules they need to really
know what the rules are and there has
been a bit of confusion restaurants have
been ordered to close but not
cafes genuinely how do you know if
you're a restaurant or a cafe I think
most people know whether they're a
restaurant or a cafe there is a
definition in the regulations a cafe is
somewhere that in the ordinary course of
its business it serves non-alcoholic
drinks and light snacks or or light
meals H what we've tried to do here is
is put in place restrictions that can
have the effect we want them to have
which is reduce the spread of the virus
now that means we have to reduce H quite
dramatically the volume of settings that
people can come together and interact
now we've tried to do that but also
build in a bit of flexibility because we
want people particularly when we've got
household restrictions in place people
can't go into each other's houses people
who live alone to have somewhere that
can go to meet a friend for a coffee so
for social isolation reasons we allowed
cafes to stay open and we've given a bit
of flexibility so that a cafe that just
happens to have a license but doesn't
really serve much alcohol can stay open
rather than closed we can be a lot more
simple but that usually means being a
lot harder we're trying to strike the
right balance here between uh
controlling the spread of the virus but
allowing as much normality as possible
leaders like me everywhere right now it
feels like we're we're holding lives in
one hand and jobs in the other and we're
trying to strike a very very difficult
balance and do that as best we possibly
can I can absolutely understand you know
the difficult balancing act that leaders
across the world are having to juggle um
you've been quite critical of Boris
Johnson though for mixed messaging so in
May you said Clarity of message is
Paramount if we're to rely on you to
know exactly what it is we're asking of
you as Leaders we have a duty to deliver
that Clarity but then this Friday you
said the confusion over cafes over
alcohol has resulted in a lack of
clarity but sometimes that's a price we
have to pay right now for trying to be
as flexible as possible so it's a lack
of clarity unacceptable when it's Boris
Johnson but acceptable when it's when
it's
you in point of fact actually I've tried
very hard not to criticize Boris Johnson
not withstanding being invited to do so
because all leaders are are making
really horrendously difficult decisions
that what I was trying to explain on
Friday is that just as I've tried to
explain to you there it is very easy to
give 100% Clarity by saying everywhere
must close everybody must stay at home
that is the situation we had under
strict lockdown as you try to strike a
more Nuance balance it does become more
difficult and there is more potential
for a lack of clarity that we try to
work through um and and give as as much
as we possibly can I I'm trying every
day you know sometimes I'll do it better
than others I'm I'm I'm not perfect at
this nobody is but every single day I've
chosen not to stop doing Daily Press
briefings I'm trying not just to H say
to people what it is we want them to do
to keep the virus under control but to
to share with people that the
decision-making process and the
difficult balances we're trying to
strike and and where there is a bit of
difficulty with striking a balance like
we had on Friday over over CAF trying to
make people understand why that is and
what the alternative would be but you
know I'm I'm not infallible in this it's
it's a difficult situation and we're
trying to do it as best we can and
strike those balances between
controlling the virus because lives
depend on that but recognizing the big
economic impact of how we're having to
do that and trying to preserve economic
activity and as much normal life for
people as we we possibly can and of
course the of difficult decisions are
made even harder when people in public
life aren't seen to be obeying the rules
you've been very strong in your
criticism of Margaret fer who you said
that she needs to resign as an MP after
she travels from London to Glasgow while
she was an SNP MP after testing positive
knowing she had tested positive for coid
19 she said that she's not going to
resign you haven't expelled her from the
party though so if she's not fit to be
an MP why is she fit to be a member of
the SNP well we' suspended her from
party membership we now have a due
process we've got to go through I I
can't unilaterally decide to expel
somebody we have a process in the in the
SNP and that process will take its
course we've done everything in terms of
an SNP membership that we're able to do
at this stage pending that due process
um I don't have the power and you know
this uh Sophie no party leader has the
power to make an MP resign from
Parliament H but I couldn't be clearer
she should step down from Parliament at
the laps of judgment in traveling at
hundreds of miles knowing she had tested
positive for coid was so significant and
so unacceptable that I don't think there
is any other acceptable course of action
for her so I've read her comments in the
media today but but I I still hope she
will do the right thing obviously just
as in uh the snp's case there's due
process that are House of Commons
processes now that you know will be able
to be deployed I'm not in the House of
Commons they are not for me but I know
that there are processes that the House
of Commons are able to go through um I
every every day I I have to stand and
ask people across the country to do
horrendously difficult things to not
visit their their loved ones um you know
right now I'm asking people to
understand why they can't go to Pub or a
restaurant and it is unacceptable that
somebody in her position flagrantly
disregarded the rules like that and I
cannot be clearer about that it is not
acceptable and she should resign now I
do want to talk to you about Alex Salen
uh your Mentor someone you work very
closely with uh recently cleared of
sexual assault important of course to
emphasize that he has been cleared but
when did you first know that he faced
these
allegations um the allegations that I
mean in terms of what allegations he was
was investigated under the Scottish
government uh procedure uh for uh
complaints that came forward to the
Scottish government H he told me um
about those complaints he told me in my
own house he showed me what he was
accused of and and he gave me his
response and including saying that he
had had to apologize for something
previously um a few months before that
Sky News uh raised a query with the SNP
about alleged misconduct on the part of
of Alex Amon so I knew about that then
and obviously I had that knowledge when
the later complaints came to light um i'
I've got nothing to hide in all of this
I H faced a situation where complaints
were raised about my predecessor um and
the Scottish government to tried to
investigate those complaints it made a
mistake in how it applied its process
and there's a parliamentary inquiry into
all of that just now but at the heart of
this and it pains me to say this because
as you say this is somebody that I have
worked with and and cared about for a
long time and and I know this is
difficult for my party but this all came
to light because complaints were raised
about Alex Ammon he was cleared of any
criminal conduct but in the course of
that and again this pains me to say it
there were admissions about his conduct
made along the way and that's what's at
the heart of this and it's age old I
guess that you know when complaints are
made against people then there's a an
attempt to try to shift the story on to
all being a big conspiracy but this is
complet that were made about him and
that is important to remember the
specific question was about when you
knew about the concerns you previously
said you first found out when Alex
salmon told you on the 2nd of April uh
now you say that you're 2018 now you
actually say you found out from his
chief of St these areop These are
different you're conflating you're
conflating two different things just to
be clear when was the first time that
you found out about concerns raised
about Alex Salmon's
Behavior you you you're conflating two
different things what you're asking me
about what I've been asked about before
is when I became aware of concerns that
were specifically raised with the
Scottish government that were then
investigated by the Scottish government
uh his behavior is a wider thing than
that and what I've told him what I've
told the Parliamentary committee that's
looking into this is that in November
2017 Sky News uh raised a query with the
SNP um about allegations I don't know
who had made those allegations I still
don't know who made those allegations H
that was about alleged you know sexual
behavior on the part of Alex Sal and I
spoke to him about that at the time but
that was different to the complaints
that then came forward to the Scottish
government that are now the subject of
the Parliamentary inquiry do you think
some people might think you're dancing
on the head of a
pinit no because well some people might
that's that that's up to them but I'm
I'm trying to frankly set out that
you're you're talking about different
things I what we're talking about is is
allegations about the behavior of a
senior politician who was your Mentor
your friend perhaps important to say he
was of course cleared from the charges
but you know some people might be asking
why you haven't been completely upfront
about when you were first aware of
concerns about his behavior I've just
told you I've just told you about the
the Sky News complaint now at that time
this was a a media uh inquiry that was
made uh by Sky Sky didn't run the story
at the time they raised concerns I spoke
to Alex Ammond at the time he denied
those ACC do anything else about it at
the time because I didn't know who had
made the complaint all we knew you said
that you forgot when you first found out
from his chief of star no I I I didn't
say that Alex salmon told me later about
the specific complaints that were raised
under the Scottish government uh process
and those were different to the the uh
quy that Sky raised I'm trying to be up
front here I this is not about my
conduct this was about Alex Salmon's
conduct what I've done at every stage is
try to make sure that the Scottish
government not related to Alex Salon but
generally in the wake of me too which
was around this time that the Scottish
government had a process in place that
allowed uh complaints or concerns to be
investigated and the Scottish government
went faced with complaints about Alex
Ammon investigated those now it seems to
me I I seem to be variously accused of
conspiring against Alex Ammon colluding
with Alex Sam and all I've tried to do
all along is make sure that complaints
about senior people in politics
can be brushed under the carpet as would
have happened for Generations this was
an issue of Alex Salmon's conduct here
and yes he's been cleared of criminal
charges but there were concerns raised
that suggest that maybe he didn't always
behave in this respect as he should have
done um and you know I've tried to do
the right thing all along and I will
continue to be upfront about that in the
face of questions as I've sought to be
today according to the Scottish Daily
Mail Alex sum's team of toing inquiry
that you haven't handed over all the
WhatsApp messages sent between you after
he was accused of sexual
harassment why haven't you um I've
handed over everything to the committee
that is relevant to the the the remit of
the committee I I've gone back and
checked actually hav seen that and I
think I know what he's referring to
which I'd be happy actually to read to
you right now if you want to okay so um
round about the time I spoke to him
about the the Sky News um query um I
sent him a message on the 5th of
November saying hi when you free to
speak this morning he replies saying
10:00 a.m. that's when I asked him what
is this Sky thing I go back to him later
that day to see any developments um and
the next day H I see you're free for a
word so I was setting up a conversation
that I have told uh the Parliamentary
inquiry about it's hardly a big
Revelation later that week incidentally
um I I message him to say no wonder you
didn't want to tell me um that just
after I find out that he's agreed to
host a Regular Show on Russia today um
and it reflects my incredulity at at
that decision and I think his response
to me then makes an oblique reference to
the Sky News um query so you know that
may be what he's talking about it's not
a big Revelation really so why do you
think that he's saying that these
messages should have been shared then um
look you'd have to ask him that I I
understand that for Alex salmon it
probably is better for the focus of this
to be on people wanting to believe that
there was a big conspiracy against them
as opposed to the focus being on his
conduct I can understand that I can
understand why people in my party might
want an alternative explanation for all
of this this is age-old here that you
know man accused of uh misconduct
against women and often it's a woman
that ends up sitting anding for them um
at the same time though you can see just
take your step back there's been
accusations uh rightly or wrongly that
you haven't shared all relevant messages
uh with the inquiry there has been
confusion rightly or wrongly about when
you knew about concerns raised about
Alex sammon's Behavior I can't help
thinking if it was another politician
Boris Johnson for example you would be
one of the people who would be
criticizing their conduct well I'm I've
the reason you know I've put all of this
to a parliamentary uh inquiry I actually
did it two months ago uh the
Committee just published it this week
and I'm really pleased that it's
published and it's out there I will sit
before this committee when it calls me
to do so to to answer all in any
questions I've not actually been invited
to do so yet you know I've got nothing
to hide here um I you know one of the
the worst things that I I've faced in a
a sort political sense because nothing's
worse than the co stuff I'm going
through uh right now we're all going
through right now but in a political
sense one of the worst things I faced
was being uh confronted with the reality
that my predecessor my mentor of 30
years somebody I considered a friend
closer to me than probably anybody
outside my family was facing serious
allegations of sexual misconduct at
every stage I've tried to do the right
thing and just finally Linda Fabiano an
SNP member of the Scottish Parliament
leading this investigation into the
Scottish government's handling of
complaints says the inquiry can't
currently proceed because of obstruction
from among others the Scottish
government so can you commit now to
doing everything in your power to assist
this
investigation the Scottish government
has already provided thousands of pages
of evidence Scottish government
officials have appeared before the
committee already one of the things I
did early on because as you have just
been demonstrating part of the committee
remit is looking at my conduct therefore
I I recused myself from all of the
decisions about the Scottish
government's response to the committee
because I didn't think it would be right
for me to be taking the decisions about
the evidence that the Scottish
government put forward but the Scottish
government has been cooperating with the
inquiry and will continue to cooperate
with the inquiry um from what I read on
the committee's website one person who
hasn't put forward evidence to the
inquiry yet is Mr salmon himself I have
the Scottish government has uh so we
will continue to be uh cooperative and
uh to do what the committee asks over us
okay Nicholas dur thank you very much
for uh coming on the program today thank
you